от я розсміялася але дуже гарно
висловилися що це
tтелеграramкореспондента я би сказала що
це чесно кажучи пониження статусу
України тому що це дико коли Україну на
міжнародній арені на переговорах такого
рівня бо все-таки пані Юлія це і
віце-прем'єрка і міністрка коли
представляє Перепрошую завгосп і
секретарка Хай найголовніша в державі
але завгосп і секретарка ну це насправді
є принизливо для всієї України за моєю
інформацією він вскочив по суті в
останній вагон і в нього навіть не було
за плановано зустріч і зустрічі
організовували отак аби щось тільки було
і я дійсно дотримуюся тої моменту тому
що якщо проаналізувати американські
джерела то там зустрівся перетнувся
побачив тобто не немає ніякої конкретики
це таке враження що по коридору бігли
перетиналися Я думаю що це є більше на
внутрішню аудиторію українську в плані
того от Ну бачите розказують що я якась
там агентура от зі мною в Штатах
спокійно говорять Ніхто мене не
арештовує Ніхто мене не переслідує але
ті рішення які зараз приймаються в
Штатах Я думаю що якраз його присутність
буде негативно впливати на них тому що
він асоціюється з корупційними
скандалами він асоціюється з ситуацією з
розкраданням гуманітарки тому що він
очолює скажемо так курування
гуманітарного напрямку а він є дивною
особою яка не має жодних компетенцій
знаєте що найстрашніше Ну от добре щось
він там поговорить щось там станеться
щось там буде А якщо нічого не вийде або
будуть погані якісь наслідки він скаже А
при чому тут я в мене жодних повноважень
немає Я ж ні за що не відповідаю я ж
просто керівник офісу президента і в
результаті в нас не буде з кого питатися
де що куди і як натворилося в тому
всьому контексті так а американська
сторона вона ж розуміє Хто це ну в тому
сенсі Да він сфоткався з Антоні
блінкіним так і песпатрон фоткався з
Антоні блінкіним ну от ви дуже гарно
сказали Я думаю що американська сторона
зокрема американська розвідка дуже добре
все розуміє але в певних моментах Вони
намагаються підтримати реноме України і
наскільки мені відомо тому що наших
депутатів не випускають на ці всі
переговори Тут їздять тільки скажемо так
обрані від слух І прислужників А немає
можливості безпосередньо поспілкуватися
то наскільки мені відомо що американці
дуже добре розділяють так звану Владу і
офіс президента і український народ і
збройні сили України і вони 100%
підтримують збройні сили України і
український народ і зрештою десь в
певній мірі намагаються Ну окей ви вже
приїхали давайте там ви собі десь
побігаєте А ми будемо робити те що
потрібно щоб Україна вистояла тому що
зрештою для реноме захисника демократії
якими яке мають Сполучені Штати Америки
зараз критично важливо знайти все-таки
можливості підтримати Україну і дати її
вистояти особливо у дуже важкий зимовий
період